here the sun rises on a crisis every day
where America touches Mexico and is
gripped by an emergency on immigration
this was the day that saw a changing of
the law
the end of the so-called title 42 that
seen a surgeon migrants towards the
United States
like this
it was the scene we saw at the border
where El Paso and Texas meets Mexico
these were migrants who'd made it before
the Midnight Hour when title 42 expires
they were among record numbers for
cross-border entries this week over 11
000 in a single day
this was how it looked at San Ysidro
across the border from California
and this was the Mexican Town of Juarez
at Matamoros in Mexico migrants young
and old swam the river that separates
the town from Texas on the last day of
title 42.
America's immigration difficulties are
writ large on the streets of El Paso we
met Wilmer and Yandel from Venezuela
with a 2027 court date for an asylum
hearing the four-year backlog measures a
broken system
what I've pulled out here are the
immigration papers with the court dates
which are set for 2027. the hearing with
the judge is at 8 30. what we need is
bus fares so that we can get to our
destination and begin working
yeah
I want to leave already because look at
the situation we're in we're sleeping on
the floor and eating whatever we can
manage to get a hold of
in a hostel across town there were
disinfecting Camp beds here they
accommodate people with young families
it's America but it's a long way from
Journey's End
for people like Mariela Rivas from
Venezuela
well my journey has been a little tough
because I'm alone with my children and
while I've had scary experiences no one
has helped me on my way over here no one
has tried to help me
the politics of this are as intractable
as the problem itself successive U.S
administrations have struggled with the
immigration issue that is big and
getting bigger it has been a defining
election issue it will be again amidst
the political noise El Paso feels
neglected just think that everybody is
focused on what they want and nobody's
listening and and that's okay but now
it's like let's let's sit down and have
a voice of reason here on the Mexican
mountains across the wall they've
written read the Bible it's the truth on
the U.S side they can't handle the truth
of an immigration system Beyond
efficient control title 42 or not
lasting Solutions remain a distant dream
foreign